the best-selling book the five people
you'll meet in heaven is touch readers
lives for 15 years now tells the story
of Eddie a maintenance worker at an
amusement park who dies after saving a
little girl named Annie from an accident
so in heaven Eddie meets five people
from his life who teach him lessons
about himself in the world that he lived
in that book sold more than 14 million
copies and thirty-eight territories has
been published in 35 different languages
people like that book Arthur Mitch
album's new book is called the next
person you meet in heaven so you might
expect it's a sequel to that very
popular story so it follows Annie as an
adult and introduces us to the five
people that she meets in heaven one of
them of course is Eddie the child enjoys
us at the table to discuss a book it's
good to see you Mitch that's great we
always like it when you come here listen
you said for the last 15 years wherever
you went people said what happened a
little girl and but it took you 15 years
to tell us why did it take you so long
well when you're imagining heaven it
takes a little bit of time you know but
you know this actually the story sort of
goes back to the whole idea of the five
people we meet in the heaven that lives
intersect everybody's connected and so I
had to sort of figure out how Annie was
connected what was gonna happen when she
after being saved ends up dying goes to
heaven 15 years later a little story
about mistakes and laws that you say
mistakes aren't always mistakes and loss
isn't always lost when you look at
absolutely right the first book and he
thought his whole life was a mistake
because he was stuck working in
amusement park taking care of rides it
turns out when he goes to heaven that he
had killed the child in war that he
didn't know about so he ended up working
as an amusement park worker to take care
of children
we never understand those kind of things
Annie is saved by this accident she
doesn't even remember it in the book so
she keeps thinking her whole life as a
mistake well she's sort of remembering
she made some kind of mistake that
somebody died as a result of she ends up
becoming a nurse because her life was
saved and she ends up saving other
people's life so the book is sort of for
people who as Maury from Tuesdays with
Maurey said to me you know you need to
forgive yourself when you reach the end
of you your life you know give yourself
is to go along because we're pretty hard
on ourselves for the mistakes that we
think we're making and they're not all
mistakes in the end we had a family
discussion about this I mean you write
here if you knew you were about to die
how would you spend your final hours
we had a family discussion about if you
knew the only had one year left on your
life how would you spend it and thinking
about death while morbid can also change
the direction of your life that's right
it makes every day precious yeah and I
think that's what Maury did and that's
what that's what the idea is behind all
of this
you know we we spend a lot of time
thinking about the losses that we have
in our lives and certainly my books have
dealt with that kind of thing there's a
moment in the book Annie Annie has a
pipe cleaner animal that's very
significant in her life and and I won't
say who does this but at one point pipe
cleaner was dismantled and someone says
to her look this is the heart that
you're born with he makes a single pipe
cleaner heart and it's small it's
perfect and then he takes the other four
and he puts them all together and it's
his big heart with lines all across he
says and this is the heart you die with
and she says but it's all broken and he
says that's right and she says what
that's what ruins it says no that's what
makes it whole and and and that's what
life really is the losses we have
actually teach us to appreciate as you
said the days that we have in the people
we have with us and the way we value our
life I was I've always been interested
uncle Addie who is the inspiration
thought he was a nobody
yeah the notion that you can have a life
that has immense value but you can still
think you're a nobody
well I think that unfortunately a lot of
people in America feel that way and
that's why I wrote this book for people
who kind of think I don't matter or why
does everything I touch go bad you know
well when auntie gets to heaven she
finds out that all these things that she
did wrong there was a consequence to
that turned out to be right and and I
think if we just look at it that way
that the things we do wrong sometimes
offer us opportunities to be better the
mistakes we made offer us opportunities
to not make those mistakes in the future
then that nothing life that you're
referring to is nothing at all
it touches all kinds of people and the
conceit of five people you meet in
heaven was because my uncle thought he
was a nobody and he once told me his
dead relatives were waiting for me had a
near-death experience and he thought
that he saw them waiting on the edge of
the bed while he had an operation and
then he told him get out of here I'm not
ready for you yet went back into his
body and lived a few years longer but I
always thought well that's what heaven
must be like people waiting for you but
what if they're not just your relatives
what if they're people who you might
have had you know just us five minutes
and you know you take a turn here
Aaron you affect their life forever so I
think if we think that we all kind of
connect we might be more appreciative
about my paper death is such a dark
topic and you seem to make it so
inspirational you read this book with
tears and a smile at the same time well
I write about death as much as just use
death to illuminate life yeah and I
think once we all realize we have
limited time we start to take life a
little more precious it's a great read
thank you so much moving it yeah that's
nice
Mitch Albom and thanks so much for your
on great to see the next person you meet
in heaven is on sale now